[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young
woman who had just tragically lost her
dad
we talked to a man who's been passed
over for number of promotions and he's
just getting bitter at work and we
talked to a young dad who's raising two
daughters by himself after their mom
stepped out stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show
a show for you about you and by you
about your mental health about your
relationships about everything
going on in the world and i'll tell you
what man we got a lot going on in the
world
[Music]
man it has been a wild wild couple of
weeks
um and i've been out for a while and if
you're just regularly getting the show
on your download feed you won't know
because we stay a little bit ahead
but i've been out
james you want to tell them what you did
you mean what you did
i don't think that's how that story goes
i think the way we should tell the story
is the way
it would be truthful
let's tell america what you did james
uh well
you gave me code is what happened
and then
turns out that you took a real covet
test and found out that you also had
covid i think i tested negative a bunch
but didn't you buy these like at the
dollar store
no i i got it from a guy in a parking
lot that true and um they were pinecones
turns out he told me to wave the pine
cone over my heart and
to sing a
song or something you can't just like
gently put the q-tip in the front of
your nose that's not how the test goes
you have to shove it way up there you do
sound terrible like you you still have
it but we're both back in action after
being gone
and um of all the things
but so if you're listening my family has
been out um man it's just kind of burned
through it wasn't great
but the great mystery here is this
gully
yes did you get going i did not get
coveted no
i really don't know how i was
so sure that with because i've been
stuck in tiny rooms with y'all for hours
i sit next to james
eight hours a day like
inches apart um and apparently i'm
bionic i have a feeling that you got it
and that you went to the mirror and you
looked really closely inside your own
soul and you said no
and it was like i'm sorry ma'am and it
left and then it doubled about that it
doubled back on me and james and it was
like sorry guys i got to give you all
double toes
uh but that lady's scary and me and
james were like yeah we know and then we
just took it yeah amazingly somehow i've
yet to get it nobody in my household has
gotten it yet knock on
whatever
i don't know how you don't now because
yes if you don't know inside baseball
here is we spend a lot of time in little
tiny rooms together and um
kelly is not made of the things that we
are made of i told her today that one
day she's gonna like cut her arm real
bad and then it's going to be just wires
and chips under there
motor oil will leak out and she'll be
like all right and yeah that would
explain a lot of things actually lack of
emotion
yeah like insane those things yeah you
know james i'm glad to know you feel
when you have heart very much so but i'm
happy to see you back but i missed you
both i just want you to know i did miss
both of you you didn't but no i did it
was a little boring my week was a little
boring did you download that did you
plug into whatever cpu that runs your
world and you're like download miss the
guys yes i did that before i got into
work this morning the script was well
good
we missed you too
so hey everybody we held it down while
we were gone man
i know there actually is gonna be four
or five episodes where kelly takes calls
and does a way better job than i do so
congratulations america you win
you win but i am glad to see everybody
and be back as we are slowly getting
everything back and by the way i'm back
in the gym we're back working out um it
is fascinating to hear the folks that
have this thing and how it just it
affects everybody differently and
affected my whole family differently so
it's just a what a
bizarre thing but we're back it's good
to see you james good to see you kelly
nikki b everybody it's awesome all right
so let's go to the phones and
catch up with kelsey in seattle hey
kelsey what's going on
hi john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling what's up and how
can i help
my my dad struggled with addiction most
of his life
and
my little brother is following in his
footsteps
they slowly lost everything and were
living in a motel up until
my dad overdosed two weeks ago oh
no i'm so sorry kelsey
thanks
my brother texted us dad's dead and he
continues to do
yeah of course
we thought it would be rock bottom for
him you know
um
i'm heartbroken i'm angry with both of
them and i just don't have the hope that
i used to have how do we deal with
how do we deal with the loss of our dad
when it was such a complicated
relationship
and how do we deal i mean how do we live
with the fear
you know that we're going to lose my
brother too
i think first is to sit for a second
and it feels like you need to run and do
and and and
folks who love
addicts
live their lives waiting for this other
shoe to drop right
and
it's heartbreaking your dad was probably
also a pretty awesome guy too huh
yeah he
he needed help that he didn't get yeah
he had a good heart but he did a lot of
things i mean he used with my little
brother
you know
i'm
just it's hard to
think about all the good things but then
there are some really bad things too yep
that's right
so
the the big elephant in the room here is
you just lost your dad
and you are
still in the middle of that trauma
and
more
making this trauma more complex
is that you had a complicated
relationship with this guy
and so on top of the normal
heartbreak that would be two weeks out
from any of us losing our parent
is also you had seasons where you hated
this man right and you had seasons where
you despised him and he was yet he was
still your dad and you loved him
and then you had hope and then he just
needs to get through this season and oh
my god he's using with my brother
but maybe they're going to be good for
so right it's this this roller coaster
you've been living with and all that
complexity is on top of this grief right
yeah and the tendency we do we have in
these moments is to try to solve it all
right now and
the hardest thing i'm gonna tell you is
you can't solve it today
yeah you just have to be heartbroken
that your dad's gone
and you didn't get that that
it didn't end like a disney movie right
right and y'all been waiting for that
ending for so long and it didn't happen
um
it doesn't surprise me it's not abnormal
it's it's equally heartbreaking
it doesn't surprise me that your brother
went right back to use him because when
you're using your covering up you are
numbing over broken relationships and
the only one he has he feels like he has
left just left right yeah and so to use
that same mechanism to cover up that
same challenge doesn't surprise me at
all it's heartbreaking and for those of
us who aren't addicts withdraw when it
comes to drugs i think so many of us are
addicts with different things
it doesn't make any sense you're just
you think like you just saw someone you
love passed away what are you doing
that's just not how that addictive brain
solves math problems right
yeah
so what's the last two weeks been like
um
i mean my sister and i and my mom we try
to support each other the best that we
can
my brother's
not really answering phone calls and
can't i mean we can't be there for him
if he won't let us you know
have you all called the police on him
um
no he's i mean he's living in his car
and
i i don't know what they would do
you can do a welfare check
and sometimes
depending on what city you live in if
they have drug court or if they've got
if he doesn't have a long record
there are
communities assistance programs that
people can
have access to through the criminal
justice system
um that's just one avenue that comes to
the top of my head or
finding the car knocking on it but i
also know you all been living with this
for a long long
time uh yeah how long has he been here
he'll text us here and there he has been
since she was a teenager okay
my mom was in a pretty bad accident and
he
ended up taking pills from her
[Music]
oh
man
it's been a long time he's been to rehab
a couple of times and he got well for a
while and
he's got two little kids and
they're gonna have to go through the
same stuff we did you know it's just
a lot
are the kids safe right now
yeah they're with their mom and
yeah she's got a good support system
okay
were you all able to have a funeral for
your dad
um
no not really we got together and kind
of
did a small thing for him just us but
how come you didn't have a a larger
funeral for him
i i don't know it's complicated okay
having some sort of ceremony to mark
this moment
and to talk about
him being the fun dad the silly dad the
remember that time
and to talk through the complexity of
who he was this is the stuff that we're
not gonna miss and also no addict i've
ever met wants to be an addict right
and
talk about
that he has peace finally right
um to be able to exchange those things
in some sort of ceremony with some sort
of people who cared about him even if
it's small is so important it becomes a
touchstone that you heal from
not marking this moment in some
important in some
definitive way it just leaves us
untethered for so so long right
at the end of the day you're in the
right place and that is heartbroken
sitting feeling like you're sitting in
the corner of your room covered up in
blankets and you just think what am i
going to do next right yeah um
that's where you should be when your dad
dies even if he was a complex man that
made bad decisions you know what i mean
yeah
yeah
how's your mom doing
um they've been divorced for quite a
while um she basically went from dealing
with him and his addiction to my brother
basically
it's been a long road for her i know
it's hard for her too but
yeah so what does tomorrow look like for
you kelsey
um
well i've got four kids so i'm gonna
do what i can't you know yeah do they
know about their granddad
um they saw him a few times over the
years but
um
didn't have them around a lot sure
so they didn't really get to know the
good parts of him
which is
sad
do they know why mommy's sad right now
uh
yeah my older ones do but my little ones
don't
yeah how old are you kids
uh
16 12 8 and 2
16 12 8 and 2.
so i think the 16 and the 8 and
the 12 year old i think they're old
enough to know about granddad and that
granddad was sick
and
i think it'd be a really neat family
thing
for you guys to write him a letter
and um
it would be a neat way for them to get
to know their granddad and how much
um
there was some good stuff about him and
there was some not so great stuff about
him
and i think it's really important for
you to model for them what grieving
looks like
and it'd be cool for them to write them
a letter and say hey we never got to
know you and here's what you missed out
on because we're good kids
and we're sweet kids and we wish that
we'd gotten to know you but we didn't
um
but we're gonna keep being good kids
and let them reiterate that does that
make sense
it's not uncommon for grandkids of
addicts to feel like it was somehow
their fault their grandparent didn't
want involvement in their life
yeah and so this is a healing moment for
everybody but there's something powerful
about writing that letter and if you
don't invite them into that conversation
i do think that's important for you
have you ever have you ever
sat down and written a letter to your
dad and let it all just out
i haven't
sounds like a good idea i've been
watching your show
[Applause]
it's a
it'll be one of the harder things you
ever do
and
the
it'll be important for you to read that
to somebody whether that's your husband
whether that's your mom and your sister
um it could be a neat moment that you
and your and your mom and your sister
all write letters to him and then you
all get together and read them too out
loud there's just something about grief
being witnessed that is healing and i
wish i knew the math on it i wish i knew
the exact
um biochemical responses in the body i
don't i know that it's healing
when people witness grief together
and there would be laughter and tears
and memories and everyone could breathe
you know what i mean
and that's how you can also get some
clarity with your brother have you ever
written your brother a letter
i haven't we've texted with him but
you know yeah there's something about
that and that may be a conversation for
you and your mom and your sister or
maybe it's just two sisters right letter
but a actual
tangible letter that you can get in his
hands that he can go back to over and
over and you tell him you love him
and um you're there for him
and you miss him and you don't want him
to turn out like dad
and um
you will be looking for him
when he's ready to get clean right and
he'll be can't wait till he makes that
choice
um but i think that's again it's one of
those neat moments that sisters can
reach out brothers can reach out to
something powerful both for the author
and the receiver of that letter
um
but that's what i would do right now in
your grief and here's the thing you may
write three or four letters to your dad
over the next couple of months
one that just says i miss you i can't
believe you died one that's is rage i
cannot believe this was my childhood i
can't believe you used drugs with my
little brother and now look at him
i can't believe i can't believe i can't
believe you didn't know your grandkids
they're awesome
and you missed out
and there may be a heartbroken daughter
to dad letter just says man i miss you
i miss you so much
and man i held out hope for you and it
didn't come true but i held out hope for
you i want you to know that right
there's something about getting that out
and writing it down letting there be
some distance between you and those
thoughts and you and that pain and being
able to sit with it
and again find somebody whether it's
your husband your wife uh
your husband your wife your your husband
your sisters your mom who you can read
those letters to and vice versa
have your husband join you he can write
your dad a letter too but
man i'm so sorry
losing a parent is heavy
and losing a parent with the complexity
of a drug addict is
it's even more messy
and then missing your brother on top of
all that is even messy on top of messi
so when those things happen when our
lives spin out on us like that writing
stuff down and getting away from it is
so helpful not away from the feelings no
not running no but being able to
to create some space between
us and that weight that blanket that's
just laying on us not letting us breathe
[Music]
and it's just going to take some time to
heal and it's going to take some months
that are going to turn into years and
you're in it now
so so sorry for your loss
stick by those that you love
so sorry kelsey hey we'll be right back
on the dr john de luna show
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day how
do i find a counselor if you can't find
a counselor in your area or you can't
afford one i've got a solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy video chat
text chat phone counseling it's a
licensed therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com slash
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available all the time
this is for you your family and for
everyone else that's coming your way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com today
all right we are back let's take one
more call let's go to joshua in
vancouver hey josh what's going on man
hey dr john uh can you hear me i can
brother how are you
oh i'm doing well well can't believe i'm
on the show cool i can't believe i'm on
the phone with you
thanks for your time oh thank you man so
what's up how can i help
okay so
uh my question is um as a solo parent
how can i best raise two young daughters
to be healthy and confident especially
kind of a
part of the question my next part of the
question is
would it be better for them
that i wait until they're adults for me
to look for a partner
um yeah
wait for them to be adults so where is
mom
mom moved out
about two years ago
she left the country and she's living
with someone else okay
yeah
how has the last couple of years been
uh
up and down
yikes man
walk me through how that how that
initial transition happened did she just
drop a bomb on you one day did your
relationship slowly lose steam what
happened
um what happened was
well i had a i had an inkling you know
something was up she was spending a lot
more time on a certain
phone game and then
found out that way that she had been uh
well actually she went on a trip
and then um when she got back that's
when i found out okay yeah
the trip was not for what she was
intended to go it was to meet someone
else gotcha
yeah
and how old are your girls
uh they're eight and my youngest is
turning uh
seven in
october oh man so they were six and
five when this happened yeah yeah and um
well unfortunately this hasn't been like
the first time that i've been left on my
own with the girls
oh well don't just don't just stop there
i mean
what happened
um
well the first time i guess uh
she
wasn't feeling as if though
i'm trying to remember here from the top
of my head now
um
she had moved out to go live with a
relative
i to remember why it was something
something that she just couldn't she
didn't want to
i don't know she couldn't live with me
or something okay
well or her baby girls right
yeah so tell me about these two
wonderful young daughters tell me about
them
well they they really are wonderful they
have kept me
going cause my face strong uh
their
their their opposite in nature and one
of them is uh really social the other
one's really quiet more like me
and um
they have been uh
they have been my everything they've
been able to help me keep going that's
awesome and vice versa right you've kept
them
plugged into like oh yeah for sure oh
and by the way you had to do this during
covid so that's fun right
yeah that was interesting navigating
single parenting in vancouver
in a pandemic good grief man
so to answer your first question
how do you raise
two daughters tell me tell me that first
question again
i'm just trying to give them the best
chance so i guess the the way
i phrased the question was how can i how
can i raise them to be
healthy and confident okay
so
there's a couple of things here number
one
their mom abandoned them
mom said i would rather a life that does
not include you in it
than one that does
and so
strength and confidence
is anchored to
our core narrative our core parent and
when our parent abandons
us leaves us
that leaves us untethered completely
right
and so you
are going to have to be that connection
that tethering that grounding for them
in a way that will feel
more than you can bear it sometimes
right
yeah what does that look like every day
that means every day you got to set up
breakfast with them if you if you can
like and i know single parents are
working 45 jobs to make stuff work right
um that looks like your social life's
gonna be greatly altered because you're
gonna be spending time with them right
and
you're going to be setting up situations
where they can go play and have
relationships and be successful as well
right so it's going to be just this mix
mismatch
mix mash whatever the words are it's
going gonna be a hodgepodge how about
that i like hodgepodge yeah um
it's gonna be tough is what i'm telling
you
oh yeah
do they know mom do they talk to mom do
they have any interaction with her
well um are you legally married are you
divorced where where's the status here
yeah let me uh fill you in here so
uh with the court we got um
obviously i have the primary what's
called your primary
parenting
um basically the almost like full
custody kind of thing and she has um
what's it called
she can
contact contact with the kids so we set
up at least one day
every week where she could uh video
message them or talk to them through um
the messenger
so yeah and uh
it's it's kind of a it's not going to be
ongoing i don't i don't know how it's
going to be because she just
to throw another bomb on top she just
had another kid i i believe
in this month
yeah yeah at some point um
man i'm
i'm going to say something that i
usually don't say on this show
i'm usually about
reconciliation and i'm usually about get
have a parent stay as connected as
possible to their kids as much as
possible
um
and also it's important that you never
run down the other parent right even in
these messy co-printing situations
i want you to meet with a child
psychologist asap have you done that
already
no
so that's a must because i want you to
get some very clear guidance from
somebody in your area who knows they've
got more than 10 minutes with you on the
phone
um
it i do not like this
electronic
mother
connectivity
right that makes sense that feels like
it's going to be more damaging in the
long term
than just cutting off all communication
that's what i was uh thinking in my
heart too i hate that that that's there
and i i know that in the back of my my
head
but you will also have to deal with and
this is a very real thing
your wife or your ex-wife at some point
will say
daddy's the one that wouldn't let me
talk to you i tried
does that make sense
and your daughters will look at you and
say dad why'd you take our mom from us
and that yeah there's gonna have to be
some really clear guidance there in that
relationship and so i want you to
meet with a child psychologist asap if
your daughters aren't in counseling they
need to be
okay
yeah um
their anchor to the world has left them
and they are all
yeah they are just hanging in the wind
and
i want to push on something you said a
little bit okay you said that they are
the ones keeping you tied to reality it
cannot be that way it has to be the
other way around
those girls will feel that weight that
it's our job to keep dad stable and to
make sure dad's okay because mom left
him and that's a burden that an
eight-year-old or a six-year-old is not
strong enough or designed to carry
oh for sure let me let me quickly
reiterate that uh i i thought i was more
answering like
what they were like like these um
these two individuals i was trying to
explain what they were like but for me
what uh what keeps me going
is my faith in god for sure okay
well i i i never want them to feel like
now that mom left it's their job to make
sure dad doesn't go crazy
exactly you know i understand that okay
so
if you haven't already um do you have a
group that you meet with
uh i just started to
the churches that i'm attending just
started opening up more of the
the group so i signed up for one
hopefully they'll go back to me soon
good sign up for a group there if you
haven't gone to meet with a counselor i
would recommend it even if it's an
online counselor you can go to
betterhelp.com i got to deal with them
you can take that man but get it i did i
did it actually excellent good for you
good for you so getting connected with
somebody that can help you begin to
parse this apart because that leads me
to the second part of this question
which is
should you just not date until they're
should you not find another partner
until they are out of the house the
answer to that is no man don't do that
to yourself right
um
the recommendation here is often around
it's out of the 12-step language but
about a year after somebody passes away
about a year after somebody just up and
abandons everybody
especially if it's just one of those
snap your fingers i'm on a trip i'm out
taking a year to learn who you are
getting your feet on the ground right
what kind of parent are you gonna be
what kind of home are you trying to try
to create here before you start dating
again
two years out man
man i highly recommend leaning into
social situations going to grab coffee
with somebody right and if have you done
that yet
no no i'm i'm still trying to
i think it's going to take me longer
than three years to figure out who i am
sure well you want hey listen you won't
have yourself totally figured out
brother and the moment you think you do
you're going to meet somebody they're
going to knock your socks off and all
that's going to change right it's more
about making sure the blood's stopped
right okay it's making sure that that
wound is healing
and so what you don't want to do is go
create a codependent relationship here
where
so you're going to be so exhausted after
a few years it's going to be tempting to
get somebody else to help babysit your
kids with you right and that's what you
don't want
um
and then obviously be careful and smart
about who you bring home
and make sure that you're not just
having a rotating cadre of
potential girlfriends coming through the
house because that's a lot for your kids
right
of course if you do decide hey i'm
serious with somebody
then man y'all go straight to a
premarital counselor where they can walk
you through what joining homes is gonna
look like what co-parenting is gonna
look like what
how you gonna involve mom at one point
when she decides she's just gonna swing
back into the girl's life and all
that's going to help you just pull each
one of those things apart and create
some sort of
context some sort of
forum for how y'all are going to handle
questions as they arise which they will
right but no man just staying
don't feel like you have to do that for
them for you
um they can still grow up to be
wonderful well-adjusted young women so
um i didn't answer your original
question here's your original question
you let those girls know that they are
brilliant
that they can do hard things and not
just with words only give them tasks let
them be a part of the household the
operation of the household right so the
temptation is going to be to take all
their chores away because you know
they're sad no they're gonna be they're
gonna function in the house they're
gonna help with dinner they're gonna
help you when y'all go grocery shopping
they're gonna help when you are cleaning
the house they're gonna know they have a
role in that home
and you're gonna honor that role by
having high standards by loving them by
teaching not losing your mind on them
right
their their esteem who they are is going
to come through participation in that
relationship in that family unit does
that make sense yeah that makes
difference that actually helped uh
answer my question um i'm doing an okay
job then well yeah and
the tendency is to either put your foot
way on the gas and try to control
everything so this never happens again
and you can't do that because you'll
suffocate somebody
or it's just to i don't want to push
them because i know they're hurting
and then the kids end up with no
boundaries man and a kids crave
boundaries right
and then making sure you take each one
of them out on a date so that they know
individually they are special and loved
and making sure that you go take care of
you that you're exercising you're eating
right you're going out with friends
you're going on dates too
and so here's here's what i'm i'm
getting at when you're at home
you are fully at home
you are the the the electronics are off
you are in their world you're asking
about their weird dolls or dragons or
whatever things they're into and you're
learning it and you're on all fours
playing with them
and then when you're at work you are
fully in work
because being guilty while you're at
work doesn't do anything except make you
less
less of a good employee and when you are
out on a date you are fully invested in
that date
right
and those little girls are with a
babysitter that you trust or with a
parent that you trust and they are um
safe and secure there you
have going halfway in on your date isn't
gonna help them either does that make
sense be where you are fully and when
you're with them be all in on them
right yeah so be just uh learn to be in
the moment kind of thing absolutely and
again i'm going to stick by
the
the always advice don't talk bad about
mom
um they will ask why did mom leave us
mommy's not doing well right now or
mommy chose to go live in another house
that's a choice she made
um i know we miss her don't we
and
you've had those nights where your kids
are bawling just saying i miss mommy
have you had those
no but they my oldest has asked about uh
your whereabouts and why yeah
and say mommy chose to go live somewhere
else and i miss her and i know you miss
her too
yeah no yeah we have had uh those
conversations yeah
if they haven't had the
balling fits the
why not i want my mom
um they're coming okay
they're coming and on those nights when
your daughter says i just want my mom
dad i don't want to talk to you about
this i just want to talk to my mom
don't get your feelings hurt because
they're kids right yeah they're just
young children and they're going to miss
their mom it's right for them to miss
their mom it's right for daughters to
want to be around their moms
um
i mean that's a special special
relationship that your ex-wife just
stepped out on ah it breaks my heart man
so here's the thing my answer was all
over the place and i apologize for being
kind of rambly
um
how do how do you know your doc
your daughters are gonna grow up to be
strong loved
young women because their dad loved them
dad told them the truth
when dad was with them he was fully with
them
dad made sure there was time for each
one of them to be known dad got them the
mental health trauma help that they need
and this is trauma because mom abandoned
them
mom moved out on them
and you can use any word you want this
is trauma this is
abandonment and they need to get
professional help for this especially at
this young age with play therapy there
can be some magical things that play
therapists can do with young kids in
this situation
and you got to trust them and you got to
lean into them and when they lash out at
you you can't take it personally even
though it's going to hurt which means
you're going to have to have your own
network of people that love and support
you
and when they
start pushing your boundaries as they
get older
expect it
love them for having autonomy and
strength and wanting to know how far the
limits of your love
they can push because they see how far
mom's limits they see how far mom's
tether went it was really short
and then mom cut it
and so they're going to want to find out
how far they can push dad before he'll
cut him loose too and you're never going
to cut him loose
because you love those baby girls
so sorry you're living in this man
make sure you got people make sure
you're honoring yourself your body your
mind
and let those girls know they are
brilliant
they are strong they are beautiful
and i say this almost every show make
sure you are getting in your 30 second
hugs a day with them if they're cool
with that
make sure you're touching their face
you're looking them in the eye
and that they can feel it
that they matter to you
sorry you're going through this brother
joshua sorry sorry man
but hey you know what i'm glad you're
the dad i'm glad you're the dad it's got
to deal with this and sit in that gap
for those girls they're lucky to have
you brother
all right man as we wrap up today's show
james
whoo
i'm back from the covens we got one in
the books
that's how you say kavit the covens the
covens
that's the least confusing thing about
kovitz so far so is that how to say it
oh man hey listen this is actually
i keep my my secret reserve of my actual
favorite songs of all time this is one
it's off the positive songs for negative
people record by the one and i think
he's the greatest working songwriter
today frank turner the song is called
the next storm
it's released in in in june of 2015
and the song goes like this
we had a difficult winter we had a rough
few months and when the storms came in
off the coast it felt like everything
broke on us at once
it's easy enough to talk about blitz
spirit when you're not holding the roof
up and knee deep in it and the pictures
and the papers got ruined by the rain
and we wondered if they'd ever get dry
again but i don't want to spend the
whole of my life indoors
laying low and waiting on the next storm
i don't want to spend the whole of my
life inside i want to step out
and face the sunshine
and we lost face if we lost faith in the
omens we lost faith in the gods we just
ended up clutching up the empty rituals
like gamblers clutching long odds and i
don't care what the weather man's saying
cause the last time that i saw him he
was on his knees he was praying and the
preachers and the scientists got got
soaked just the same i can't even read
today james and we wondered if they'd
ever get dry again
i want to step out
and face the sunshine
right here on the dr john dolone show